we'll just call him Logan it's a young
guy ambitious is started listening to
some of my stuff went to another guy who
was a little bit older and then tried to
learn the basics of editing video Logan
went to the business used the buddy who
taught him a little bit about editing to
get a job interview and he' learned
enough that he could get a job offer he
gets a $60,000 offer which a solid
amount of money for editing with
basically no experience just from the
small amount of skills he was able to
learn rather than accept the job he
asked for $3,000 more because because
what he thought he had to do was earn
rather than learn who cares the business
is obviously not going to do that